the missing piece that caused a
mid-flight blowout has been recovered
the door plug that blew off from Alaska
Airlines flight 1282 landed in a school
teacher's yard the hole had left behind
now being combed over by federal
investigators and the questions it's
raised
multiplying by late Monday the two main
US airlines flying Boeing 737 max9 had
grounded the plane so have some carriers
outside the US United Airlines said it
found loose bolts on multiple aircraft
and Boeing announced it will hold an
employee town hall meeting Tuesday to
address the
issue flight safety experts say luck
played a large role in preventing
casualties on the Alaska Airlines plane
the seats next to the hole in the
fuselage were vacant and the plane was
still climbing had the aircraft been at
higher altitude at cruising altitude for
example maybe more passengers would have
unbuckled their belt could even have
been moving back the cabin and then
certainly would have been a risk of loss
of life with uh passengers potentially
able to be sunked out of the aircraft
but questions remain about whether the
plane should have been Airborne at all
investigators say a pressurization
warning light had turned on during three
recent flights it was very
benign uh nothing occurred very benign
the light illuminated they flipped it
they reported it it was tested uh by
maintenance and then
reset but the issue was never fully
resolved and Alaska Airlines limited the
jet to Shorter trips as a precaution
until Friday's incident Boeing has come
under increased scrutiny since more than
300 people were killed in 2 737 Max
crashes in 2018 and
2019 those were linked to a software
defect now the company faces another
crisis and the company Airlines and the
government are working to understand the
problem and restore passengers
confidence Mike Hanah aljazera Arlington
Virginia make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer